let's now go and talk about the senate i
have to tell you that the senate is not
looking so bad now we'll look at the
general senate numbers in a moment but
there are three prominent republicans
who as of right now are losing their
senate races let's talk about them one
by one first and foremost val demings
member of congress democratic member of
congress former police officer she has
decided to challenge marco rubio the
incumbent republican florida senator for
his seat she's currently winning by four
this could go in any direction between
now and november but we're only two and
a half months away and to be such a
long-time incumbent senator as marco
rubio sort of a celebrity senator to the
extent that he ran for president and
he's more well-known than you know uh
pick whoever ben sass i don't know uh
senators whose names i don't even know
um and so the fact that he is down four
is not insignificant as the hill reports
val demings leads rubio by four
according to a poll released tuesday the
poll is from university of north
florida's public opinion research lab it
shows deming demings at 48 rubio at 44
7
saying they would choose someone else
now much of that 7 percent will
ultimately vote for demings or rubio so
that is very very interesting now a
couple of other races that are
interesting there is the mehmet oz
versus john fetterman race in
pennsylvania in the senate there as i've
told you before this is a race that
could decide whether democrats or
republicans control the senate after the
november election
this is not a race that is looking very
good for mehmet oz despite all of his
personal wealth and uh cringe ads and
everything the latest fox news poll has
it at fetterman plus 11.
the fabrizio anzaloni poll has it at
betterment plus six usa today fetterman
plus nine those aren't particularly new
polls but on average right now according
to real clear politics fetterman leading
oz by on average 8.7 points that's good
news for democrats as well
and then lastly
in georgia and this is a really scary
one because it is way way way too close
in georgia incumbent democratic senator
rafael warnock is trying to beat off a
challenge from herschel walker herschel
walker is the republican nominee who
cannot speak who cannot put together a
coherent sentence and yet somehow look
at these numbers warnock yes he's
leading but he is leading by only an
average of 4.4 points in that race
walker cannot think and cannot speak he
understands not a single political issue
and he's almost within the margin of
error
that is
endlessly endlessly horrifying about
what it says about the united states and
its electorate now overall how are
things looking for the fall if we look
at the 538 forecast in the senate
democrats are now up to a 61 chance of
of holding the senate this is a number
that started at roughly 50 50 months ago
and over time
the scenarios have shifted more and more
and more in favor of democrats holding
the senate now 61 and 100 doesn't mean
democrats are likely to have 61 seats
not even close in fact as you can see on
this graphic the most likely scenarios
are either another 50 50 split with
kamala harris being the tie-breaking
vote meaning democrats control democrats
having 51 seats or 52 seats those are
the most likely scenarios but a 61
chance of holding the senate when really
republicans should be taking it
historically speaking
um is not altogether terrible and then
over in the house of representatives the
odds have improved just marginally for
democrats but still roughly a four to
one edge for republicans a week or two
ago i told you that democrats had only a
20 chance of winning the house that has
just barely inched up flaccidly to 22
percent from 20 so in in all likelihood
democrats will lose the house but if
indeed they maintain the senate they
will at least be able to prevent
republicans from doing any serious
damage now also in terms of the senate
north carolina is in play uh florida uh
um
rather 538 has north carolina looking
similar to florida in terms of the odds
that a democrat takes that seat
and we are going to continue following
all of these numbers but the most likely
scenario the closer we get the more we
can kind of narrow our prediction
the most likely outcome right now is
democrats hold the senate lose the house
and we have just vile obstruction
for the next two years and nothing gets
done
and then republicans use their own
obstruction to try to justify voting for
a republican for president in 2024
because joe biden didn't get anything
done for those last two years thanks to
them of course so that's where we are
right now i look forward to taking your
questions about the 2022 midterms during
our upcoming member only
viewer town hall
we do many
wide open full audience viewer town
halls we are holding an exclusive event
on wednesday august 31 at 6 pm eastern
time where members will be able to call
in and chat with me we will stream the
event for everybody but only members
will participate if you would like to
participate simply sign up at
joinpacman.com